[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever
we love sucka you're scared oh cat's
here
hello why does your parents name you
after a cat
isn't my name my actual name is cat teen
and like a canteen kinda yeah is that
french or something no
it's uh vietnamese it's pronounced
geckin uh
but when i first met my boss i said my
name and he's actually
he has a hard time uh remembering
people's names and mine is a little
exotic
so he's like oh can i call you cat and i
was like yeah sure and i've gone by cat
ever since
yeah so not until your recent job you
went by cat so yeah every
like your whole life before your job
yeah it's kind of weird because now i
feel weird saying cat teen
okay like i forget to introduce myself
to people i don't think yeah
do you only go by like tiff now you're
like oh hi i'm tiff and say like i'm
tiffany joe's tipped out real that's
what she says no her whole instagram
people are calling me tiffany i'm like
who's that yeah that happens because i'm
like hey i'm ice man and i'm like i'm
sorry i'm steve
you get it all mixed up yeah nobody
really calls me katina anymore it's
it's kind of like i can differentiate
how people know me now
because if you call me cat teen you
probably have known me for a while it's
like
pre-podcasting and if you call me cat
then it's like post podcasting
in some cultures when you become a new
person you get a whole new name
yeah like first and last just i don't
know if they had last night
like marriage yeah true did you
did you take your husband's uh last name
uh
i could have given myself a middle name
oh what would you choose if you could go
back and like give yourself a middle
name
donut tiff doughnut no donut yeah like
donut
i almost i almost went with naomi
because that's the name that i would
always give
like fake name in clubs but i
had your real now you got to come up
with a new name when you go to a club
i know right now because tiffany's a
pretty [ __ ] name already
but hey i'm a naomi it's a little less
[ __ ] really i find it harder do you
yeah it's like remember naomi
it's an english name and a japanese name
what's a smutty because like if i were
you i would give like
a [ __ ] uh like stripper middle name so
when i give it to people people don't
believe me like oh i'm cinnamon
yeah you know like and they're like oh
you're clearly lying like no i'm
cinnamon i like cinnamon crystal's close
enough where i'm like okay you could be
a stripper
my childhood best friend's name was
crystal so so to me it's like that's
crystal did she ever strip at any point
in time
no that she knows that i finished that
one oh damn it
cut you off candy is a stripper
yeah candy for sure is tootsie is it
deliciously named tootsie delicious
i don't think so nope i don't believe so
no way
i kind of missed the days where people
named their kids like alligators
is there a celebrity child named apple
yeah
yeah yeah or what's elon
musk's uh some [ __ ] formula yeah it's
like
xenon the word the quadratic formula yes
it's literally easier
for the bagger and theorem oh you
already have a name set up for your
guy's kid right but you can't reveal it
until i cannot i can't wait
do you in case you have a name for your
the 2b
baby babies how about charlie no we're
not charlie don't you like charlie
because no she hates charlie
charlie's like oh we just we've been
thinking of girl names
but for boy names like forget it no idea
obviously you're thrilled about the idea
of having a boy no i wanna actually i
would love to have another boy
i would love to because boys are so easy
i already raised one like
i love it i love having a boy i look at
girls they look easier
grass is always greener though you know
no [ __ ] way i mean i don't know
because i don't have a daughter
being a girl yourself but being a girl
myself and knowing how complicated i am
how is it harder
well we there's just way more emotion i
mean have you ever thrown a basketball
at a tv
breaking it's expensive that's like
every day so boys are more expensive i
have never done that
yeah not every boy does that oh maybe
it's just this i didn't need to act out
to get
attention oh yeah i should put stuff in
the sockets
were you a difficult daughter no i was
that kid
i was always like a loner as a child
like if you turn on a tv i will
literally sit there and watch for six
hours why couldn't all kids be like
i would watch the dumb issue like old
stuff like i would watch like two and a
half
men yeah like wait that's all to you
that's old to me because i was a child
when i came out
i remember when that came out but like
my grandparents only had like the first
like few channels when like uh like
they had like 1 through 12 and on like
channel 6 or whatever it'd be like two
and a half men
i'd watch fear factor when it came on
stuff like that dang those are i
remember when those shows were new
and they first came out i was like in
middle school-ish
i think i like playing in my neighbor's
yard me too
[ __ ] yeah yeah just hop into their
backyard and play
um you're like a latchkey kid right yeah
oh [ __ ] maybe that's why i just like
adventuring and going out with my
friends because it's just
it's like being in elementary again full
circle
whenever you hang out with joe it it
does become an adventure
you you actually getting to start from
beginning from beginning to end yeah
honestly i didn't quite but in hawaii
so joe met up with us in hawaii like
four or five days later how many days
later we got
yeah like four days three three four
days something like that i think it was
like four days
and pay attention we are trying to but i
was like i
caught a moment of my own retardation
and i was like what the [ __ ] are we
gonna have to separate you too
i'm sorry oh wait what was funny i want
to know i'm
so funny it was just dumb i was dumb i
didn't speak english
you'd like to share with the class might
as well
well i was talking i'll say is it i was
like is joe an adventure from beginning
to start and he goes no from beginning
to end and i'm like why did i say
beginning to start
all right start oh it doesn't make any
[ __ ] that's so dumb
so from prequel to c no is this prequel
to pre yeah
i was like i'm so stupid sorry
i'm sorry too i'm sorry sorry tiff
anyway teacher continue
sorry miss naomi i visited them in
hawaii
yeah no yeah so we were hawaii right for
like three four days it was just
uh casey isaac me and david your second
son four of us
and and then so during that whole time
isaac was just so anxious he wanted to
go places you just want to do things
story of my life and then
i know so then like the whole time
where's uncle joe the three adults like
we're just like oh man we're tired dude
like we're just trying to relax be on
hawaii time
you know just [ __ ] just chill you
guys do you just want to lay on the
beach
no that's all that's all we did we just
ate they napped three times a day
yeah why why didn't he go like snorkel
or something oh because
like some of these maps were at back at
the airbnb place and
it was too far from the beach anyway the
point is when joe got there
it was like yeah because isaac was like
jumping on the curbs and [ __ ] and there
was joe doing the exact same
thing i was like we did parkour that's
ty
parker before breakfast yeah he was the
kid that was missing on this trip
and then we woke up at five in the
morning and i woke his ass up
to go run on the uh jetty you know the
rocks
and then to see the sunrise and i'm like
man i'm like
how am i older than you guys and you
guys are more tired than me i don't
understand that's why you always got to
have joe around
dude you're the uncle with the doctor
i don't want to go on another vacation
without you being there to entertain
isaac
i'll take isaac to be a babysitter i'm
like i'm the one having fun with isaac
and i'm like
come on and they're like nah we're not
gonna do i'm like what the [ __ ] dude
yeah nice looks like i'll go
yeah he was the only one that would want
to go jump clips with me i like how hey
tiff what was your favorite memory with
joe when he took my son
away played with him
because he's old enough now to hang
because when we went to hawaii like what
like almost
seven years ago i think he was six i
think we were doing the same [ __ ] but i
had to do extra work
and he was boring as hell because he was
so stupid
he wouldn't get your [ __ ] jokes too
like now he gets now he gets all those
jokes he's the perfect ripe age of 13
where he's
just immature enough to like hang with
joe's is perfect
he's reached joe's brain level
13 years finally a 13 year old we're at
the same stage man
come over and throw basketballs at the
tv
he's too young to get the [ __ ] jokes
you guys can act out yeah
i'll no the whole time we're like man
why are they so tired and i'm like i
don't know and then we just kept jumping
in the
um you know like the tide pool then have
you been to the mermaid
yeah yeah so like the water comes up and
then you can jump off the cliff oh
that's tight
but if you if you don't do it while the
water comes up
it's like really shallow it's dangerous
the tide goes out and it pulls you out
and we're like trying to [ __ ] come
back in the shore
yeah he got all scratched up and he's
like look mom yeah
today's video is brought to you by feels
baby
feels so good okay check this out so you
know
when i usually use fields is because i'm
super high adrenaline from like coming
back from extreme sports or whatever but
i've been trying something different
right
so um my next thing has been stretching
so i have a wind down routine now so
like
because i forget like okay i'm always
like lifting or like running but then
i'm not stretching enough yeah and
they're tense like this
yeah i'm super tense right and i was
thinking well
if cabd helps you loosen up like
mentally and everything else
of course it's probably going to be even
better when you do stretch or do yoga at
home
and then it actually does work out
pretty well like i feel like i'm
floating on the cloud
yeah i personally feel like i'm able to
go past my limits
way quicker on cbd there's not attention
just relaxing
yeah and i just feel better in the
morning because like at night
i'll bust a hot shower take some drops
of fields
and then i'll do like a good ass stretch
session and then
i sleep like a freaking baby dude that's
awesome yeah
and what's dope about feels too is they
offer a free cbd hotline so if it's your
first time
and you don't know how much to take you
could talk to someone and to help guide
you through it which is super cool
and also it's a subscription service so
if you don't know even if you don't even
know where to go and get it you can
order it online
and right now if you go to fields.com
that's f e
a l s dot com off the record you get 50
off plus free shipping on your first
order which is super good so give it a
try
50 off at fields.com off the record
plus free shipping you know what feels
should do is they should start a guided
yoga hotline so they can
take the cbd and then like do a
stretching session
how about that feels damn give him
royalties that boy almost drowned too
and i was so proud of him because he
didn't
you didn't tell me this park remember
when he drank all that water and you had
to rub his back and [ __ ]
yeah cause we swam all across the power
plant wow
and then um but that's what he needs
though as a young boy he needs those
experiences to exert that
yeah he needs to get roughed up and i'm
sure with with coronavirus right he
wasn't able to hang out with his friends
all the time true
so now he got to hang out uncle joe
exactly my boy
but you swam across the power plant what
the [ __ ] does that mean oh okay so like
that's true there's this area called
electric the simpson's powerpoint like a
nuclear plane
he's swimming inside three-headed
octopus just is it like nuclear
like starfish with 20 lakes it's just
this area on the island
that is really cool but we don't want to
tell you you could google it yourself
there's a massive power plant there damn
it now they're gonna find it we swam
all over it like it was like probably
like half a mile or more
it was a lot like we and then like we
didn't have anything
to hold us up so we just had to keep
going and he's like i'm tired and i'm
like i am too just keep going
and he drank mad water and then he was
like grabbing onto my leg and
like he's like i swallowed so much water
i couldn't breathe and i'm like just
swimming your back and he's like all
right and then afterwards we got off and
i'm like i don't want to swim back and
he's like me neither so
we walked all the way back oh really
that's what you did i want to hang out
with uncle joe in hawaii bro you sound
like you have some dope
i don't want to almost drown have to
hold on to his [ __ ] leg
that's the bonus that sounds like elbows
from that first hawaii trip when isaac
was six
he was terrified of the water back then
but
because swimming with joe and like we
went on the snorkeling trip and we just
got to see a whole bunch of like
stingrays and turtles and it was really
beautiful and
during that trip is when he finally got
comfortable because joe was like
really patient with him trying to teach
him and that was awesome like before
hawaii memories with joe yeah that's why
we're announcing this is a plug
travel joe it's a new service you can
take joe with you that'd be kind of fun
a travel
adventure see joe giving like guy like
guided tours
making people do adventures yeah you
know he wants to almost drown with me
almost drowned with me yeah oh he almost
jumped where i almost drowned
where she please
that's close to where we found the dead
body when we're hiking you guys remember
that there's actually a seal so it could
have been mistaken for a dead body
wait you got that the power plant is
where you threw up last time yeah oh
okay yeah cause i had a um i had a
snorkel
and i forgot to stop breathing when i
dove to see a
fish so i saw nemo and then i kept
breathing and i
the water was like wait this is water
and then i was like choking and i swam
back up
yeah it took him a couple minutes to
realize he was [ __ ] choking on her
yeah he's like i'm uncomfortable but i
don't know why
but this fish is so cool i'm like i'm
choking
what happens to me in my dreams when i
dream that i'm swimming underwater and
i'm still breathing i'm like oh [ __ ] i
could breathe under water
because i forget that i'm dreaming i
think do you wake up choking no
because i could breathe it's not actual
water
have you been to hawaii uh yeah kitty
cat kitty cat
uh yes i have i'm actually going back to
hawaii in
uh may i'm so excited i'm going to maui
coming up
yeah i've never been in maui before ooh
nice is there any place like i should go
one on there the sunsets are amazing on
the west side oh the volcano thing that
hike
that's what there's a little hole there
yeah there's a uh
there's a hike i don't remember a blow
hole i think of royals whenever you're
blowing
yeah imagine like like a geyser right
where the water just goes
yeah and it's tied because the weight
yeah the wave comes in and then like
there's just a
hole in the cave and it shoots it up
yeah it's pretty crazy
yeah there's a lot of dope stuff you'll
like it and then the sunset will
change color like 20 times i'm so
excited i love
the last time i was in hawaii i think it
was like in middle school and just
remembering like
wow this is so pretty people get to live
in paradise like this is [ __ ] insane
yeah and then i went back to mainland
like what the [ __ ] is this
all this building [ __ ] i want to go back
to the beach
yeah i want to be able to get spam at my
local mcdonald's
yeah the 7-eleven the 711 has so much
good [ __ ] spam souby
and just food in general that place
hawaii's magical dude it really is
if you hire joe for twenty thousand
dollars to be your travel guide
you can almost drown too yeah i wanna do
that actually i wanna do a meet up
travel joey i think it's gonna be big
when corona is over
yeah i'll do a fun like travel meet get
up
but people have to sign waivers though
cause i don't want no bitch-ass people
getting hurt and suing me
true that's their fault if you get hurt
it's not for the week i'll tell you that
right now
hanging out with joe not for the week my
lady gets mad at me because ever since i
went hiking with joe
i used to not like hiking and i would
tell her like you know we should go
hiking more i watched one with joe and
it was so fun
and she looked at me and she was very
upset because she likes the light
she goes like the [ __ ] ass hikes yeah
that's exactly what it is the [ __ ] ass
hike so i'm like oh
wait which one did i take you to we just
went to eaton canyon oh yeah yeah yeah
that made you like hikes well it just
was like it's the company
it's the company dude your life sucks
cause we did some crazy [ __ ] we went in
the the cold ass
water water fountains right right i
don't consider that a hike
it's a stroll yeah now at the end we it
was winter so it was really cold
well spring right yeah kind of it was it
was cold it was pretty cool
it is the company though because i think
like if you whoever you go with
kind of dictates what the landscape or
terrain becomes
so if you're with like someone that's
more free like everything's a playground
versus like watch out for that much
after that what's your favorite what
you're trying to say about my wife
we're in hawaii i propose to her the
next day we're
we get into a car with her old man and
he proceeds to drive us
all the [ __ ] over hawaii and all we want
to do is like go to a beach or something
but he's like giving us a tour of
[ __ ] so you're staying in the car
like
i want to enjoy this jungle what the
[ __ ] can we pull over and walk out can
we do anything so you're just stuck in
the car
he takes us up to north shore which
we've already seen before we get out of
the car for 15 minutes he's like okay
let's go and we get back in the car for
three more hours oh my god
so he does it like that doesn't even
take three hours to get from one end of
the island
did that day he went all the way around
yeah the long one
he did no he wanted to take us the
scenic route and all this [ __ ] and we're
like no
we did not consent to this pal pal yeah
dang dave so that's exciting it's so
exciting i love it you're gonna love it
i don't know i don't know what to do in
hawaii but i feel like the older i get
all i really want to do is sit on a
beach and then like nap
that's all i want i want to eat right
and stockpile on the only fans
yes take creatures on my feet and save
them one day one day of work
what does your man do while you're
taking pictures of your feet is he just
like oh sorry i didn't know you're
working
oh no he's like moral support like
you're doing great sweetie
does he give you any tips does he do
touch-ups no i do everything myself
i feel i'm very embarrassed to take
photos in front of other people
so like if we're in say like a hotel
room
and i want to take a photo of myself in
this hotel room
i need to do it in a spot where he's not
like the opposite end of the room i hate
the thought of anyone
being in the vicinity of me taking a
photo i'm embarrassed so you're always
setting the timer and setting
it and then you gotta go yeah or
sometimes i'll put it on record and then
do screenshots of that recording oh
that's smart
so you wouldn't do it outdoors that is
hard no i'm too nervous for it i'm too
anxious but what if your fans want
sand and like i bet you could sneak it
it wants to be
like in a different environment yeah
you're in a bikini it's appropriate yeah
it is appropriate absolutely can you
imagine chicken and bikini squatting
over taking pictures of her feet
it's a great visual yeah should have a
photo shoot like maybe you could train
your boyfriend on how to take pictures
for you i'm sure he would i just like i
suddenly don't know how to smile
probably dude
same i go from like a regular smile it's
like i look like i'm
nobody over your feet oh yeah so like so
like
you could pretend like he's taking a
picture of you but it's down on your
feet
they like feet and face a lot of people
like feet and face is what i've
like i think it's because they associate
like the bottom of your souls with like
a specific face
so they want mr potato head yeah just
the two feet here in the face
oh it's uh is it like it's not mister or
mrs potato height anymore right it's
just potato heads
each individual one does still have that
but
over our overall brand is the potato
good it used to offend me
really thank god right do you not feel
like you're represented
i don't like that we have to share a
podium that is being a person with a
potato
um okay that's right that's fair
potatoes are potatoes
yeah don't humanize you you don't think
they've paid their dues
you know i really don't i've heard that
argument though
teach their own no but i totally relate
to that whole taking photos thing
because
i don't even know i'm like there's so
much
like people who can take like instagram
photos they're like out about in west
hollywood at that like pink wall
like posing and [ __ ] doing like
different angles it's definitely
like it's a special skill in my opinion
to be able to take photos in front of
other people watching it reminds me of
like being a kid and the most
embarrassing thing is like wearing a
puffy jacket at school
like that's how i feel taking photos in
public i feel like i have a puffy jacket
again
but now puffy jackets yeah it's the
hottest [ __ ]
so now taking is a lot of [ __ ] i look up
to the chicks who can get out of a car
they go to like what was a crime scene
yesterday or perhaps the building burned
down a family is sad they have
chernobyl girls yeah all that [ __ ] and
then they take a picture
and a thong yeah in a vlog next to it
[ __ ] and they're like why is there so
much tragedy
and then they get right back in the car
and they drive away and they never think
twice about it i
wish i could have that kind of mind my
buddies just went snowboarding sorry
they just went snowboarding and there
was a girl that just hopped out the car
in a bikini took a picture in her like
suit like her snowed goggles
and then got in and just left wow and
it's like all right cool
you're not gonna even snowboard a little
bit sun i mean snow
this one does it for the ground like i
drove by and then we just saw like two
13 year olds having like a straight up
photo shoot and i'm like
wow this is crazy or like a tick-tock
session where they're just oh yeah see
that too
dude i was just trying to do a photo
session right here when you guys all
went out for a walk
and i put my phone like on my trunk
right there and i was like trying to
pose i'm like
i don't know what to do but that's your
job right like that's so that's normal
you're actually getting paid these
people aren't getting paid just like
it's just a part of their life now like
a random 12 13 year old
doing photo show photo shoots with each
other this is crazy your picture should
be that like
it really is no i'm going to show you i
took a million
i know imagine if i picked it like this
imagine every single one like that i
would like that
i'm all trying to be like this but my
face is like
you got to do that one photo with the
girls doing this you could be the honest
you know how they do that yeah i like
the high fashion like ponytail on there
and they hold their hair the [ __ ]
arch and [ __ ] the honest chick on insta
i like it
that [ __ ] that's actually good like one
picture will be really nice and then the
next picture is like oh this is like
even get the nice picture nick i'll give
you some tips you know what a lot of
girls will do
they'll do that like expectation versus
reality photo but both of them look hot
they're like oh my god i love that what
has to be ugly whenever social media
isn't real like you look
hot as [ __ ] on both shoulders stupid
idiot and that's what that's what they
want they want everyone in the comments
what i do no oh come on
you're still a bad [ __ ] that's what
they want you to say like yes queen
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you